heute was fordern Sie heute Abend hier
bei 8:15 Uhr Group sie meinen ihr
bezüglich Atom oder was sie heute Abend
bereden wollen
ich will dass wir sagen wir müssen alles
versuchen um diesen Krieg
ich sag mal zurückzufahren und sozusagen
einzustellen und nicht mit Waffen
konstant zu verlängern die wollen sie
das konkret machen und das kann jetzt
entscheidet über Jahre
ich bin eben der Meinung dass wir auch
mit Amerika sprechen müssen denn der
Amerikaner versucht immer hinten von
hinten ich sag mal alles zu tun um
diesen Krieg zu verlängern und er macht
Geschäfte damit er hat ja auch im
Handelsplatz es wurde ja hier
angeschnitten hat er ja klar gesagt dass
er wird dass er jetzt das Gas liefern
kann und das alles zu wesentlich teuren
Preisen da er will die Großmacht groß
Macht bleiben und die anderen klein
halten auch Europa das ist so also da
bin ich also es ist ein bisschen zu
einfach ganz ehrlich gerade haben die
Deutschen immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen dass wir uns in eine in eine
einseitige Abhängigkeit zu Russland
begeben und es wurde von deutscher Seite
immer regiert
sich gerade heraus dass die Amerikaner
schlicht und ergreifend Recht hatten mit
Warnung und von deutscher Seite wollte
das niemanden
Amerikanern vorzuwerfen das siegas
liefern wollen finde ich jetzt ehrlich
wir sortieren hier einmal wirtschaftlich
ein weil da wurde auch gerade etwas
vermischt das Handelsblatt hat im Sog
von Amerika hier ist die Headline hat
gesagt dass Amerika profitiert das ist
auch so aber sie haben ja gesagt gehabt
dass Amerika alles steuert diese Aussage
da wollte ich nämlich mal fragen weil
das wird jetzt überall getitelt und das
sorgt ja für Unverständnis dass er grob
sagt Amerika würde alle Steuern das
klingt ja sehr nach einer
Verschwörungstheorie das ist nicht ihre
Meinung ihre Meinung ist das Amerika
Amerika ist es nicht unrecht sag ich
dass im Prinzip nachdem er ja mit China
auch die Probleme hat und nicht will
dass China größer wird stärker wird und
selbstverständlich Russland darf nicht
stärker werden und deshalb war es auch
natürlich nicht in im Sinne von Amerika
dass wir diese Geschäfte 20 Jahre
positiv gemacht haben mit Russland weil
damit natürlich Russland
gesagt wurde wirtschaftlich und auch
Deutschland natürlich und jetzt ist
durch diese ganze Geschichte wird Europa
geschwächt weil es ist ja nicht nur
Deutschland sind ja auch alle Europa
wird geschwächt dadurch wirtschaftlich
geschmeckt und damit ist Amerika
natürlich ganz sicher die große anders
denn schon Obama hat ja gesagt wie er
ist eine Großmacht und Russland sein nur
eine regionale die Fakten sind anders
auch die Amerikaner im großen Umfang
russisches Öl gekauft als billiger war
als das eigene dabei so ist es nicht und
was die sich Milliarden an Waffen
liefern Ukraine die werden nicht bezahlt
das quasi ein Geschenk der Amerikaner
kriegen die nie Geld dafür und dass wir
LNG jetzt Flüssiggas kriegen aus Amerika
immer froh aber er kann es haben es war
froh sein dass wir das kriegen eine
andere unrechtlichkeit ist dahinter in
Deutschland ist Fracking die Methode
dass wir Amerikaner in Amerika wird
gemacht in Deutschland ist verboten war
nie durchsetzbar Baden-Württemberg aber
wir kriegen könnte man wir könnten für
30 35 Jahre durch Fracking Deutschland
so Versorgung sicherstellen das will man
Deutscher nicht macht keiner das Gas aus
Amerika ist Fracking Gas dort ist es gut
für die Umwelt weil es weit weg ist in
Deutschland ist es Tabu und wird nicht
gemacht das ist die Scheinheiligkeit
dabei aber die Amerikaner haben die
eigentliche Rivalität mit China nicht
mit Russland Russland ist militärisch
eine starke Atommacht zweitstärkste der
Welt aber wirtschaftlich immer noch
klein Helmut Schmidt sagt oberwolter mit
Raketen die eigentliche Konkurrenz zu
Amerika ist China und Russland und die
Aktivitäten keine Schwächen Amerika in
der Rivalität in China dort ist
entscheidend
dass Krieg per se eigentlich immer
schlechtes weil Krieg natürlich
Wohlstand vernichtet eine macht auch wie
Amerika die jetzt ja Milliarde und
Milliarde auch rein buttert um dort in
der Ukraine die Fahne der Freiheit
hochzuhalten die
ist ja nicht weil sie da Lust und Laune
zwar da wird Wohlstand vernichtet so als
wenn man ein Haus kaputt macht und
danach sagt und jetzt bauen wir es
wieder auf mit dem Geld mit dem man das
Haus aufbaut könnte man viele viele
andere Dinge machen Universitäten
bezahlen Forschung bezahlen das Leben
vieler Menschen wahrscheinlich viel
angenehmer machen das heißt was dort
passiert ist eigentlich ein großer
Vernichtungskrieg auch von Geld ja und
ich glaube sie haben das vollkommen
richtig gesagt das Geld was dort
vernichtet wird
das Wortes das könnte man auch nutzen um
viele viele andere Dinge zu machen
beispielsweise die Freiheit auf diesem
Kontinenten aber zu machen wir müssen
auf einen Punkt schon noch mal eingehen
den da sowohl das Handelsblatt
geschrieben hat als auch Herr grub dann
ja auch wiederholt hat es ist ja schon
so dass Amerika gerade als
Industriestandort eher aufgewogen wird
und Deutschland runtergeht aber auch
wissen woran es liegt und möglicherweise
und das ist das was man ja von
Unternehmern und sie haben es ja gerade
eben auch ganz toll und plastisch gesagt
immer wieder hört ist natürlich in
Deutschland
Problem dass wir extrem hohe
Produktionskosten gerade beim Thema
Energie haben und wenn man sieht wie
viel Energie beispielsweise
Stahlhersteller brauchen oder auch die
chemische Industrie sie kommen ja auch
aus der Region sag mal weiteren Bereich
richtig immer teuer in Deutschland ja
aber wir sehen natürlich jetzt dass
Energie noch mal extrem teuer geworden
ist und es ist auch gar nicht richtig
erkennbar bei der Politik die die
Bundesregierung macht speziell der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister dass man sagen
kann wann wird Energie denn
möglicherweise eigentlich mal wieder
günstiger wenn ich das als Unternehmer
habe und sie sind ja ein Paradebeispiel
dafür auch wie man langfristig plant
Herr grob dann muss man sich als
Unternehmer ja fragen ja bleibe ich denn
einen noch in Deutschland oder mache ich
die nächste Investition für eine Anlage
aus der Tasche und mit Schnitt mit dem
Finger einfach mal so entscheide sondern
die ich lange planen muss in der
Millionen Jahren vielleicht auch mehrere
Millionen vielleicht auch 10 Millionen
vielleicht sogar eine Milliarde fließt
mache ich die eigentlich in Deutschland
dann mache ich die da wo ich sicher sein
kann
technologieoffenheit ein Stichwort ganz
Energie oder das versucht wird Energie
günstig zu halten und dann in die USA
und bleibt nicht mehr in Deutschland die
machen sind in Amerika nach Amerika
Bräuche des Skills selbst dringend die
Highways die Infrastruktur ist ja
miserablen Zustand ist amerikanische
Bildungssystem die dürfen nicht nur die
Eliteuniversitäten sehen ist der breite
nicht gut die bräuchten das Geld im
eigenen aber sie würden nicht
widersprechen der These dass die
wirtschaftssanktion Deutschland mehr
treffen als Amerika und das ist ein Fakt
ist über den man reden muss und auch
über alles reden immer so aber musste es
einordnen in der richtige logische
Entwicklung und wir haben hausgemachte
Probleme die jetzt akut erkennbar sind
wir Strukturwandel nicht betrieben
Deutschland wir haben viel zu sehr
Staatseinfluss auf die Wirtschaft dabei
gehabt wir haben die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der eigenen Land
nicht hinreichend gestärkt wir haben die
Steuerschraube überdreht kaum ein
modernes Wirtschaftsland ist so hohe
steuerliche Belastung wie Deutschland
haben wenn sie den Leuten alles Geld
wegnehmen dann haben sie nicht die
Möglichkeit für Investitionen gerade
nicht das Gefühl dass die FDP da gerade
groß gegen angeht welche Note würden sie
eigentlich gerade ihrer Partei geben
und es ist sicherlich ein Punkt für die
auch mal eine Partei immer gestritten
hat lasst den Leuten mir vom Geld übrig
wir haben Staatsanteile und Umverteilung
die nicht effizienter sind zum
Bundeshaushalt an ich habe nichts gegen
Sozialpolitik Buch um das Geld hin wir
haben es nicht Infrastruktur die Bahn
funktioniert hinfahren nicht empfehle
Ihnen mal Fahrt mit der Deutschen Bahn
Freitag
Forschung Hochschulen vielen Sektoren
eben nicht up to date sind wir haben
falsche Sektoren investiert wir haben
ständig auch im Sozialbereich weiter
mütterrente und sonst was eingeführt und
dort wo die Zukunftsentwicklung ist in
der Grundlagenforschung den Entwicklung
haben wir nicht das Geld investiert aber
wir haben eine schiefe gerade fragen wir
doch mal Frau Kelle und Herr grub
vielleicht sind die offener mit
notengebungen das verstehe ich auch es
ist ja auch ihre parte Frau Kelle welche
Note würden Sie denn der FDP aktuell
geben mangelhaft aber ich würde es der
gesamten
koalitionsregierungskoalition geben ich
weiß gar nicht ob man das jetzt der FDP
alleine an haften also zu Schulden
kommen lassen muss weil die FDP
möglicherweise noch eine Kraft ist die
Vernunft reinbringt aber ist nicht
schafft natürlich auch jetzt sagen wir
mal in diesen in dieser
Kräftekonstellation durchzudrängen was
mich was mich viel mehr beschäftigt ist
und was ich eben vermisse auch in dieser
gesamten Situation ist so etwas wie eine
general general Mobilmachung eigentlich
für Deutschland für den Energiesektor
wir haben so viele hat es ja schon hat
es ja angesprochen wir haben ja durchaus
Kapazitäten in Deutschland für
Energiegewinnung die wir schlicht
untergreifend aus ideologischen Gründen
nicht anfassen das heißt wir sehen
gerade zu wie wie eine Destabilisierung
der gesamten Wirtschaft passiert mit
einer Kettenreaktion ja Unternehmen die
nicht mehr produzieren müssen irgendwann
Leute entlassen sie wandern vielleicht
ab das heißt wir haben sozusagen eine
kein überhaupt keine Perspektive
Deutschland von Leuten die abwandern
wollen ich höre seit Jahren Menschen von
Menschen die aus Deutschland auswandern
wollen und es werden immer mehr und das
wird das sind nicht die Leute die in den
Sozialsystemen sind sondern das sind
eigentlich die Leistungsträger die sich
fragen ob sie eine Zukunft haben in
diesem Land und da fehlt mir wirklich
der Wille also auch der sichtbare Wille
im Moment in der in der Ampelkoalition
dass man sagt wir brauchen jetzt
wirklich eine stabile general
Mobilmachung für Energie in Deutschland
und da müssen wir jetzt alle über
unseren Schatten springen und da geht es
gar nicht um Universitäten Straßen oder
die Deutsche Bahn da können wir alle
jetzt mal ein paar Monate darauf
verzichten aber wenn wir unsere Arbeit
doch doch ich glaube dass das so
angesichts dessen was worauf wir gerade
zusteuern das Deutsche Bahn verzichten
ja nein ich meine die Investitionen
darin die ja das ist im Prinzip eine
luxusdebatte weil wir laufen auf ein
Problem zu dass viel gravierender ist
und was auf die nächsten Jahrzehnte
nicht mehr erlaubt dass wir
Investitionen machen in Schulen oder in
Bildung oder Universitäten sondern es
geht langsam an die Substanz und da wird
würde ich mir wünschen einfach auch ein
Wirtschaftsministerium eine Regierung
die wirklich alle Kräfte mobilisiert und
das bedeutet dass man nicht irgendwie
Monate braucht um zu entscheiden dass
man von drei Atomkraftwerken zwei jetzt
vielleicht doch weiterlaufen lässt dass
wir frechen haben nein aber all diese
Dinge ich meine warum diskutieren wir
nicht mal wirklich konkret einen Plan
für Deutschland wie wir energiemäßig
autark werden eine einer der erlaubt
dass wir vielleicht irgendwann mal auf
billigeren Strom kommen
abholen weil ich glaube das würde die
Sendung gesprengt Frau Kelle gibt
mangelhaft welche Note geben sie denn
sie sind doch ein Mann der Klartext
kann ich verstehen aber in der heutigen
Situation aber ich muss jetzt mal sagen
Demokratie ist natürlich die
schwierigste Regierungsform denn ich sag
mal gerade wenn wir jetzt sagen wir
haben drei Parteien und hier und wenn
ich dann die Opposition eine höre das
ist ja jetzt im Moment die CDU und der
hat der sagt 1&1 ist zwei dann sagt der
andere garantiert das ist drei verstehen
sie da wird nur Kontra gegeben und nicht
auch mal zugestimmt ich würde natürlich
in einer Regierung auch mal als
Opposition sofort sagen das ist top das
würde ich so machen und die wir müssen
das Ausbauen und so weiter aber wenn wir
schon dann recht unser Rechtssystem so
ist dass wenn wir Windräder ich sag mal
wenn wir das alles veranlassen wenn wir
Jahre brauchen bis die genehmigt sind
und gemacht sind da muss man natürlich
auch etwas trinken aber das ist hinter
der Demokratie gesagt ihr Unternehmen
könnte jedenfalls mit Windrädern und
Solardächer nicht funktionieren also
insofern ist es vielleicht grundsätzlich
der falsche Ansatz nein ich sag mal das
ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel dass wir
sagen wir können ja überall Solardächer
machen wo sie wo sie machbar sind nur
für uns wäre das mit eigenen
solartechern nicht machen
und die impliziert auch eine Lösung